hey it's Joey and welcome to better
ideas now a lot of people in this highly
digital social media-driven society are
finding it increasingly difficult to get
work done without being distracted by
the social media i've experienced the
same problem whether it's endlessly
scrolling through the newsfeed on
facebook hitting that discovered tab on
instagram just constantly refreshing it
or just binge watching youtube videos
but i've been fortunate enough to
stumble upon four awesome tips that have
really helped me increase my
productivity decrease the amount of time
i waste on the internet social media in
general all without compromising my
ability to be reached by other people
number one install the newsfeed
Eradicator Chrome extension News Feed
Eradicator is a free extension that
blocks your Facebook newsfeed and
replaces it with a motivational quote
you can still access messenger and view
notifications but it stops you from
endlessly scrolling which is the main
problem we're trying to avoid here this
is definitely one of the best and most
easily implemented strategies to help
you stop smilin scrolling through the
Facebook newsfeed number two is delete
the Facebook app off your phone and
replace it with the messenger app this
is helpful for the exact same reason
that my first tip is helpful it keeps
you away from the newsfeed the newsfeed
is bad news why do you need to know what
meme Johnny Smith tagged Suzy Q in two
hours ago it's useless it's crap stop
wasting time on useless unsubstantial
things and start getting good meaningful
work done number three is install the
forest' app on your phone there are a
million videos explaining what the
forest' app is and as millions of
downloads basically I'll just put the
link in the description you can check
that out my fourth and final tip is
possibly the most practical and the most
important don't use social media first
thing in the morning try having a one
hour period in the morning where you
don't check social media don't look at
the internet and just dedicate it to
starting the day off right maybe eat a
good breakfast take a shower get dressed
into something fly and then make a to-do
list for the day or read a book starting
the day off right by doing something
productive well
the tone for the entire rest of the day
studies have shown that willpower is a
finite resource that depletes throughout
the day the more decisions you make
which means in the morning when you
haven't made any decisions at all make
the right decision to do work and use
that tremendous amount of willpower you
have to get important things done if you
follow these four tips you have my
personal guarantee that social media and
the internet will start becoming less of
a problem in your life
and you'll get a lot more work done if
you like this video and want to see me
make more be sure to hit that subscribe
button down below if you haven't already
like the video if you liked it and
comment if you didn't or comment if you
did it doesn't really matter just leave
something in the comments because I love
looking at comments and I respond to all
of them catch you in the next video